welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
today i'm very excited to be joined by
louis adams dunstan who is the director
of business development for a company
called darwin recruitment
lewis has worked in the industry for
nearly 10 years and in that time
has progressed from consultant all the
way to director level
achieving rookie of the year and more
recently perm sales consultant of the
year along the way
and for the last four years lewis has
been involved in building the american
uh division and part of darwin and now
lives
in the states in boston lewis thanks for
joining me
thanks for inviting me just give us a
pleasure seen you seen you on linkedin
for years
i feel i feel like i've made it mom i've
made it
now i mean i'm excited to dig into uh
your journey
but where i want to start is in your
opinion what characteristics and traits
do you think
make up a highly successful recruitment
consultant
yeah this i would say the first thing
that brings to mind and this is
something that took me a while to master
and i'm not even sure that i've still
mastered it but patience
stop thinking short term short term wins
are great and you know you'll get some
cash in the bank but
they are only short-term wins so
build relationships be collaborative be
patient with those relationships don't
push them too hard
and that will set you up for success in
the future long term with uh
with clients and candidates so that's
that's pretty much the core
for me to success that i've seen um
i mean i've been doing it for 10 years
i've been somewhat patient
i haven't jumped ship yet yeah so like
and and do you think
part of like what can maybe sometimes
make it difficult to see
what the long term looks like like when
you was maybe a bit more short term
was it did you not have goals did you
have goals like
did you have complete clarity on right
so all of this what i'm doing today
hopefully will help me get here was that
part of the trouble could you not
see have your head above the water sort
of thing
yeah i'll be honest it's difficult
because when i first started in
recruitment
i entered into an environment where
there were loads of really high
performers
and not so many juniors so i was kind of
like
delusional when i went in and i was like
wow this is this is some life
you can just come in and go out every
night and you know enjoy
enjoy yourself buy rolexes and nice
suits and
and i was just like i can have that
tomorrow and then i realize you can't
and it does take time and you do have to
set goals and those goals
aren't just monetary you have to set
personal goals development goals you
have to
think about um you think about the
future and
it's difficult to do when everyone's
already there around you
so that that yeah that's an interesting
dynamic isn't it and i had
i'd um record an episode with um
a lady called gabby who sort of spoke to
that where
she entered the the environment and saw
all these people doing really well and
that actually had a knock-on
effect on their confidence but what
you're saying is actually when you see
all these people around you living the
uh
recruitment dream it's like i [ __ ]
want that now
yeah really it really motivated me to be
honest but
it motivated me in in different ways and
i actually realized that
that particular environment at the time
although it gave me the foundation
of my kind of knowledge today it wasn't
necessarily the right environment
for me to be able to grow so i mean i
guess we'll probably dive into that a
little bit but
i i moved away from that business to go
and find a smaller shop
that was going to give me a lot more
attention a lot more focus um
to hopefully then get me to that level
you know yeah yeah sure so
let me just ask that question then
because that was one of the things that
i get asked quite a few times and the
listeners
want me to ask um is so obviously yeah
so you
you started the deco group obviously
huge brand huge organization loads of
process um
great training no doubt and then
obviously yeah you've been part of the
darwin journey for
is it what nearly seven years or a bit
longer seven and a half now i think
yeah yeah so so you just mentioned that
so obviously look there's pros and cons
on both
but for you like talking to people
listening like
should i enter the world of recruitment
into a big corporate
should i leave more of a smaller agency
to go to a bigger corporate light
how would you describe the positives and
negatives would you say working for a
larger organization
compared to a growing more smaller um
business yeah so i would say
certainly at a deco i mean it's an
interesting i guess with dividends as
well it was interesting journey how
i even got into recruitment but more so
when i got there and
i was just set back by how many people
were there
we got sent on a training course um
which is up in birmingham or something
like that for a week or two
and the teachers were great but i was in
a group of like 30 or 40 people
and although that was good to have lots
of experienced people
some not so experienced around me to get
different perspectives
the difference i noticed moving to
darwin was that there wasn't as many
people in the group it definitely felt
more like a one-on-one
and it just felt easier for me to add to
kind of put my hand up and
and for someone who didn't know much
about the industry asked for help
so for me personally although i built
all of the foundational experience that
i have
at a deco and i'm thankful for that i
learned a lot faster in a smaller
organization
interesting how would you describe your
first year in recruitment less
it was i was hungover a lot um
yeah no it was making making deals then
if you're going out for the drinks or
what
well that's that that's the thing so i i
i picked up all of the
all of the skills that i needed and it
just
took me a while you know i i although
thought i knew recruitment really didn't
it takes time
um but i was celebrating like i was
doing deals
and that created like a very
confused path in the first year or two
of my career
um as to what was success because i was
feeling and experiencing success when i
wasn't actually
making placements you know on a large
scale
so it was it was a confusing time um but
it was fun
we had a lot of fun um would i would i
have changed my journey into a crew but
maybe not because it did give me that
immediate insight into what being
successful might look like um i think it
might have been
for me personally in terms of my
personality a negative feel for me to
walk into somewhere
and it take me two years to even see
that kind of like
or experience that kind of lifestyle i
needed to see it in order for me to want
it
yeah got it got it so keen to to really
unpack
the the darwin journey but final
question on the sort of early days
like obviously one of the the great
advantages have you already said like
being
joining a large organization you can get
access
to high-performing billism and
recruiters right so i guess
you've already shared what you think
make up um a successful recruiter but
was there any sort of common themes or
things that you saw from these high
performers in in that environment
i think the confidence was amazing to me
like
i've i guess my ego at one point was
pretty high and it probably still is
somewhat but it's definitely been
dampened
or like softened a little bit just
because i don't want to be perceived as
a dick
all the time but when you look back at
some of the high performers they were
just
so confident um they entered every
single month
with pipeline um which allowed them to
be confident
um they were like just resilient as well
you know when when i saw
the failures just didn't seem to hurt
them as much as it did me if i had an
interview drop out it was like
the end of the world i really didn't
know what i was supposed to do next how
i generated another one
but they were always keeping consistent
pipeline
and that gave them confidence and they
walked around the office with confidence
and
for me as a junior i was like man i want
to be these guys
so i think i think that really stood out
for me um
i actually knew the guy who brought me
into recruitment quite well
and he was one of the high performers at
computer people at the time and he
showed me this paycheck
one day and it was like 27 000 pounds or
something i was like
holy [ __ ] like that's you just i own
that that's what i was earning annually
at the time
um if not if not slightly less and he
showed me that he was like you know do
you want to get into recruitment i was
like what the hell's recruitment
so so there is an interest there is
quite an interesting story
of how i got into recruitment um but he
was someone that i aspired to and he
worked very closely with me initially
and um and yeah just just screamed
confidence he's now got his own agency
and
super successful love that so
let's talk about the the journey for the
last seven a bit years and mate so just
for context so
um have you in the last seven and a half
years with darwin so have you always
recruited in tech
always tech yeah always tech um so
joined in
as a what a recruiter i'm a human or
resourcer
right yeah yeah so joined as a trainee
essentially i
i left computer people and was just
looking for that smaller shop and was
happy to just get the opportunity to
learn so when
as a trainee consultant yeah and then
you've been on that
typical trajectory of people that
achieve it of like getting in at that
level to to now obviously
direct to ship right and we'll unpack
that
um yeah have you always been then final
bit of context for people listening have
you always been in perm then
or is it being contracted what's been
your journey with that yeah always perm
i think i've probably placed
three contractors in my career okay to
predominantly
yeah or always pay me all right so
let's talk about that first year quickly
then rookie of the year
yep why did lewis achieve that
um i i entered into a new market
was working the danish market it was
untouched for our business at the time
and to be honest with you it was
pretty untouched by recruitment in
general so i
i did definitely have some level of
advantage going into this market it was
a market that was picking up it was
booming
um there were some hot technologies that
just landed around kind of node.js
angular javascript at the time and
no joke when i was calling clients or
prospect businesses
and saying hey look i've got this this
guy a girl that could be interested in
business these are skill sets they were
like wait what
you're gonna help us i was like yeah
yeah yeah i'm gonna help you it just
cost you twenty percent
i was like oh cool um let's get started
it was like wow this is
this is really it honestly it was so
untouched
i probably could count on one hand the
amount of competition i had and and even
then we weren't
there was so much opportunity there we
weren't even knocking heads and when we
did
there was like a really good level of
respect that
you know we are the almost the founding
fathers out here
of of the recruitment space and i know
it's changed quite a bit since then but
um
that allowed me to to pick up some
really good businesses and
repeat business was the key to success
in my first year
uh multiple placements you know two or
three companies that that really valued
what we did
as yeah let's talk about that for a
second
for a second you can sort of share how
you've refined this or got even better
at this as you've gone on but
so i guess firstly like what so just for
context what did you end up building in
your first year then do you know
156 okay thousand pounds pretty much
just
stand start marketing marketing didn't
exist
clients we didn't have um and i'll be
honest you know i
probably fluffed up some of the numbers
to even get my job in the first place so
i
i ultimately said i probably did better
than i i actually did
just to secure the job because so i kind
of almost applied an immediate pressure
on me
um to perform which which actually was
really beneficial
so they expected more from me than
actually i'd ever delivered
[Laughter]
so so when you started to realize that
this was untapped like what did you do
to
make sure you weren't complacent
um i i spent a lot of time
going on business trips that was that
that kind of stopped me being complacent
because every time i went on a business
trip
i forced myself to go and meet new
businesses and i really enjoyed that
part to be honest like
who doesn't traveling going out having
nice meals
going for drinks like i tried to to make
the business development side as fun as
i possibly could for me
and i think from a young age when i
spent a lot of time on golf courses and
around like
older people i developed an ability to
be able to just communicate with people
from all different walks of life quite
quickly
so i just enjoyed it mate like that
that's what kept me fresh
um consistently trying to create new
relationships and
quickly the team developed and grew
around me um i wasn't
actually initially leading that team as
it grew we had a couple of different
managers that done that
until there was a point where you know i
i got kind of tapped on the shoulder and
was like hey do you want to lead this
team and
everyone seemed to kind of buy in um
but yeah just just keeping it fresh by
by consistently meeting new businesses
and new people
so how how long did you work the danish
market then before you transitioned to
the u.s market
so um in terms of joining the business
um i was there for four years four and a
half years
yeah four years and then uh and then we
started transitioning handing over
everything we had in denmark
literally i mean it was crazy we was
working all hours under the sun but
until two three in the morning we were
incubated in the uk but working the us
markets
and okay yeah it was it was really it
was really fun we built a really good
team up initially
and um and we just we just enjoyed it it
was quite nice waking up at 10 o'clock
in the morning
going to making some breakfast going
down the gym and then starting my day
like at 12.
so that that was pretty cool but it was
a slog
it was a real struggle yeah yeah
definitely keen to dig into that but
yeah just i just want to make sure that
we just uncovered some learnings that
you experienced in the
yeah going from untapped market doing
that first year and then you let's dig
into the us if that's a code view
of course yeah yeah so so four years on
the danish market
when did you start taking up management
responsibilities
so i won rookie of the year 10 months
into my career at dawn
um and shortly after that seven months
after that i actually
moved into a senior position and then
about a year or so after that i moved
into a team leadership position
so yeah i led that team for just just
kind of two issues
and how many people ended up in that
team uh six people in the team
okay nice so how was um
how did you manage that like just having
to focus on lewis and lewis's billings
to
being responsible for other people how's
that transition to be honest with you
it wasn't smooth um i
just assumed early on that i could just
hire people that were like me
and they would just follow the same
process that i did which really didn't
have my structure
and they would just pick it up you know
maybe i was a little bit sport when i
went to the market the bd came easily
you know now we're like two or so years
in and
it started to get a little bit tougher
because more agencies are out there
winning business
um so my initial approach was wrong i
just you know i hired
a couple of people that were very
similar to me and they were really good
but it became
a challenge because we had three or four
personalities that were exactly the same
and and it was yeah there were some
heated moments shall we say
but they were all but they were all
super capable individuals
like some of them have gone up in fact
one of them has gone on to start his own
agency
um a couple of them have gone internal
um
but generally speaking very good
individuals we just
i just should have created a little bit
more diversity and i didn't really know
what that meant
when i first went into leadership
because what would you do different then
to avoid that i would just be more
open-minded when i was interviewing
um i wouldn't be asking specific
questions that i
were relating back to me and i i
shouldn't have been looking for people
that i wanted to go for drinks with
um you know that that kind of i should
have perhaps separated that
personal interest just to have a good
laugh
as opposed to like what's going to make
this team successful
so i think the interview process and
let's be honest like
we're all recruiters and we all give
advice on on
what people should do when they're going
for interviews but how many of us
actually know how to interview
like a very small percentage of us
actually know how to interview
effectively what traits to look for um
how not to be biased like it's difficult
like it is an art
um yeah i think there's like a lot of
people who are quit to do what you did
and then they then learned right okay we
need to actually build a bit of science
around what we're looking for what we
need
where and and those things right exactly
yeah
yeah we just we just didn't have that
when we first started um
so we kind of we started to develop and
change that
and we brought in some different people
from across the business
not necessarily just managers like there
is an element of
of involving other people and empowering
people in the business that can be
involved in decision making when it
comes to growth
that just does so much good for the
company
um so we changed that and we started to
see much better progress
interesting so what would you say was
the so at deco did did you do the uk
market
yeah yeah java so what what keen to get
your thoughts on this for the
for the america as well but like in in
the danish market for those listening
that might be
i don't know in the process of expanding
to the eu and
other markets but like what would you
say were the main differences in terms
of culture that you had to
adapt to quite quickly and learn and get
better at
between here in america between europe
and the day in the day yeah in the
danish market what things did you have
to pick up on quite quickly in terms of
the culture that you had to adapt to
to be honest with you in a danish market
you could just be very direct you go
straight to the studio straight to the
cto or the higher manager
tell them what you've got um they're
quite direct
kind of black and white people as well
so you know bring value immediately
um and and they'll respect what you're
offering
um you can only really do that if you
actually research your business and
understand what they're doing
understand what they might be looking
for that's the quickest way to add value
like putting that little bit of time in
before and then going straight to the
straight to the heart of the business
you know whereas moving to america
we thought we could essentially bring
that same approach here
and it just worked and it didn't it
it just didn't we failed miserably at it
and we struggled to pick up business we
pissed a lot of people off um
we realized that actually there is a
much bigger
focus on internal recruitment out here
in america
and that actually a lot of the internal
recruiters of businesses
essentially are your clients and if you
try yeah if you try and bypass them
or try and kind of cut them out they do
have the power to stop you working with
the business
so there's an element of just kind of
we didn't know that when we first got
here so we we just kept making mistakes
and then just over time we started to
realize that wait what are we doing
wrong here
and we had a couple of good
relationships with recruiters and they
can do so much for you
and any recruiter that really values
your your worth maybe even they've come
from an external background themselves
so they know what a grind's like you
know
um that will still involve hiring
managers
it's just a slightly different sell you
just have to convince them that you're
not trying to
like push them out of their role you're
not trying to create an opportunity for
for them to look bad actually what you
are is an addition to their
skill set and actually their ability to
be able to build a good relationship or
partnership with an external agency is
as valuable as them finding candidates
themselves
yeah that's really interesting so let's
talk about
um the journey of america then so then
so where where
why did lewis get this opportunity to
look at the american like where did that
come from
how did you get that opportunity i think
to be honest i've always quite i found
it quite difficult to have like
a really clear vision of where i wanted
to take my career
but i had really good management around
me that could see potential in what i
was doing
and the impact that i was making they
kind of saw and was like okay cool
you're really someone that people follow
that someone wants to actually kind of
imitate and and potentially try and kind
of like be
in terms of a competitive nature around
recruitment and i think that would be a
good trait to take to america and and
i guess just my enthusiasm
my pat i guess you can confuse it
for passion uh for recruitment and just
like
winning my ceo kind of had a chat with
me and said hey do you want to
kind of lead out u.s operations and i
was like okay that sounds cool he said
oh i think about it i was like i'll do
it
definitely i've always wanted to live in
america i don't know why
yeah i i guess i'm a golfer as well so i
guess the goal factor is good which is
kind of one of the reasons i wanted to
be here
um but yeah just gave me the opportunity
and and then kind of like along the way
trained me to
to get to better understand how to run a
business
just from a business strategy
perspective as opposed to just a
recruitment perspective
yeah so like what what was the go to
america strategy so
so obviously one obviously made plenty
of mistakes but like what was the actual
initial plan
how long was you going to be in the uk
for and build it up before you try to go
over
what will tell us a bit about the plan
and how you approached it
yeah so the original plan was we've
grown a team to
four or five people um which we're doing
in the uk which was kind of difficult as
well because we gave the opportunity for
anyone internal to put their hands up
um and no one did
so oh yeah surprisingly i think
we we had quite a young culture at the
time it's much more diverse now
um and i think it was just a big change
for a lot of people
um our office is located in essex in
bitterricky
hq and i think people just really liked
being in
essex i don't know but it's quite a big
jump to take for you know someone in
their early 20s i guess
and the commitment initially as well
which would be to be working from 12
to 11 12 1 2 in the morning and pretty
much sacrificing your personal life
for that period of time before we get
there so there was an expectation around
us being able to achieve certain figures
over a three month period
that would then kind of unlock the door
for us to go to america that said
okay now we're profitable to be able to
cover the costs of travel
visas salaries commissions everything
like that
and and was out of interest it was a
hundred thousand dollars
per month for three months consistently
so 100k months
100k months for three months
consistently and to be honest with you
yeah
it was it was a stretch um
what would what did you end up doing
like finishing when you was experiencing
the danish market was you did anything
near that
in terms of the team in terms of like
yeah billy just billing yeah billings as
a whole did that seem like completely
unattainable
it didn't because as far as the the deal
size and deal values go out here
like they're not comparable so i was
probably averaging between 12 and 15 k
in denmark
my average deal size and i finished on
250 300k
year on year for you know for some time
and we did a couple of placements in
america quite quickly
and they were like 30 40k each
and it was like holy [ __ ] why is that is
that because salaries are large is it
because the percentages are bigger
why is that salary just larger the
percentages aren't
aren't big well i guess they are
comparative to denmark you know it's
much more
um you you see kind of 20 22
25 sometimes even 30 percent it's much
more common in america
yeah and then depending on what kind of
market you're working obviously like we
kind of shifted towards data eventually
the average salary ranges between 150
and 180k
okay so yeah so you had to do 100k
months three months back-to-back
yeah did that to like so you mentioned
you did a couple of deals quickly like
how
how did you even approach this because
america is so vast
like what state did you go after did you
just focus on one state
how what was the strategy well that's
to to be quite honest and i you know i
wouldn't be lying and saying i think
that's what our challenge was
is that we didn't have a clear enough
strategy
to turn around and say okay these are
the exact markets that we're going to be
working
these are the technologies that we're
going to be supporting these are the
types of businesses we're going to be
focusing on
and don't get me wrong like we were all
experienced so we kind of knew what we
needed to do
but we it was a lot it was a lot of
trial and error
and i think yeah if we were to do it
again we would go in with a much clearer
strategy with much more research
in terms of like which locations which
technologies which businesses
also on top of that where are we most
likely to be able to grow
in terms of the actual team itself and
um initially we was actually going to
atlanta so i was quite fortunate to go
back and forward to atlanta
seven or eight times um meeting
businesses
checking out offices um obviously
running the social side of it as well to
see what it was like to actually live
there
and it was fun it was super fun but it
was very clear that
in i guess in the south the salaries
were just
so much lower really and funnily enough
i ended up leveraging one of my
relationships
from denmark with a gentleman that ended
up going and working for a major
corporation out here
and he brought us in and secured the
client in boston
so he was like yeah he that and that
kind of actually shaped the rest of our
business because we ended up with a load
of machine learning roles and we all
looked at each other like what the
hell's machine learning really we were
yeah we were going for like front end
back end product based roles and and
there's huge demand for that
but the salaries are a lot lower and
then we we learned about machine
learning
i think one of our first placements in
america was an nlp guy
and and the fee was like 40k and we was
like
what yeah cheers so
instantly that carved out our strategy
we was like okay we're now they are
experts
um at least not experts you know we were
gonna develop
that because so i think what i love
about that lewis is like
a lot of people can not give themselves
an opportunity for that to happen and
what i mean by that is what
you did was take action right and i
think like
that's the sort of lesson there really
whereas yes ideally if we were to go
back and start again let's have a bit of
a strategy and a plan as to what we're
going to focus on
but at the same time don't discount the
power and take an action
and learning making mistakes then going
actually [ __ ] this is a great
opportunity here we are let's go do you
know what i mean
absolutely so how did you go about
learning that market then
once you recognize that i think there's
really only one way to learn it and
that's to
be in it so picking up the phone
talking to any of as many people as we
could in the industry
um i mean we're here now right you're
asking me questions everyone loves
talking about themselves
so it's very easy to talk to someone um
leverage that next relationship with the
next one and the next one the next one
and just just ask just ask questions
like
i'm a true believer in there's no stupid
questions
um actually you're stupid if you don't
ask certain questions
because at the end of the day if you
don't ask them you don't pick up that
knowledge and you end up missing out on
a placement or
you know an understanding of a job
requirement you end up taking too much
time trying to
trying to find the wrong people so i was
always cool with just asking
very basic questions and and looking for
very basic answers
and i guess data science is quite a
broad term
we kind of initially really kind of went
into a niche of nlp and machine learning
and natural language processing it is
pretty simple to to understand
and once you get that understanding of
it what's also very good is that
there really is only one or two
different styles of nlp
candidate that are good um and then
you've got all the aspiring ones so we
instantly knew who to reach out to that
would then
lead to us having really good product to
take to the market
right so how um how long did it take to
get up to the
100k months it took a while mate
it took a while um it was funny because
we we actually
we hired a guy and in his first month
did four placements with a business and
did 98k
like and was like they went in
within i think we was actually at our
christmas party and he got four
separate calls from the hiring manager
saying we're hiring him we're hiring him
we're hiring him with her and him and we
was like
what so we that was the first time that
kicked in and that was after
three months that we kind of got very
close
and then we kept like having one month
where we almost got there then we'd miss
it then we almost got there and we miss
it and we were incubated for a year and
a
half
before before we got to that point it
took a while
that being said there was also some
processes and stuff
behind closed doors that were going on
in terms of getting our visas
um securing office locations um
everything else that goes with setting a
business so it wasn't
that kind of unlocked the door then that
would allow us to get everything in
place and i think it was 2017 or 18 now
i can't remember in in january that we
arrived
um as as three people so so just real
quick one so if i'm
if i'm listening right now and i'm in
the process of building out a brand new
market or looking at building out a
market like how
how long would you give it do you think
then because you've done it ended up
doing it in the danish market done in
the us market like
yeah how long should i be giving it
before i'm like right actually do we
need to pivot do we need to make changes
what would you say is like the ideal
time period
i would say the ideal time period is six
months being that you've done the
research prior
i think you have to allow for time and
especially now the way things are
you know um with the world and and
covered and what have you
six months is a is a fair run rate that
allows you to pick up business that
allows you to make some progress build
relationships
maybe get a client or two that might
have multiple hires um
at that point if you're really not
seeing progress i would really consider
pivoting into a different
industry or or sections yeah yeah
so so lewis what was your most effective
way of growing your
client base then in this american market
so you went on that
trial and narrow journey of yeah machine
learning old contact helped you
and not focusing on that like what ended
up being your like
main way of generating clients
recommendations that
almost plain and simply i even when i
didn't place people
i asked for recommendations um even if
they went to a new business
i would follow up with them see how they
were getting on um
even when i did place them you know even
more so following up seeing how they're
getting on in the job
asking about who they know and it's
quite it's somewhat of a small market
the machine learning world when it comes
to like the the big
the big fish or the big players there's
a lot of aspiring data scientists
but it is quite a close-knit circle and
if you land a good client or you land a
good contact
you're kind of in a very very good
position and i was very fortunate to
land a client
and the particular gentleman that
founded that company was
one of the godfathers of of nlp and
having that access to his business in
terms of growing it
which firstly they were paying like
three 400k
per employee that they brought on so the
fees were [ __ ] huge oh my god yeah
the fees are huge but
these are like the most elite people in
in in america
but that gave me access to call people
and say hey i'm working with this guy
and regardless of whether they they were
interested in moving or not they wanted
to talk to me
so it kind of i was very fortunate in
that sense
and and i think anyone can do that if
you pick up the right business or you
find the right leader
you leverage that to then you know make
yourself more successful elsewhere
so you you always you always hear like
referrals right but like
like in your opinion you mentioned a few
ways but like in your opinion
opinion like what would you say is the
best way
of consistently generating good leads
and referrals
i think consistency is like you just
said just being consistent
always adding value um
people don't necessarily want you to be
consistently following up saying how are
you
like what you've been up to this weekend
like people people ain't got interest in
that unless you're friends with
them and you know i've developed quite
good relationships with people here to
the point where we probably could do
that
but always trying to bring value then
meant that anytime an opportunity came
up
on their side that they could recommend
me for they did
um so i just stayed very consistent in
that
and and it's very easy to do when you
have a niche because
you can always so when you when you say
value lewis people be going what do you
mean like value what and what
how do you mean so enough right now i
mean i run my own podcast which is
certainly one value that i can bring you
know i can give them a platform
to actually come onto my show have
access to a network that they wouldn't
normally have access to
and talk about themselves or an
interesting project or an experience
that they've had in their career
that's one way another way is
introducing
other people to them that are also in
the space
like i don't know why people don't do
that more often
being the connector so it's like would
it be like
hey lewis look um we spoke the other day
i spoke to this
other lady the other day who's on a
similar journey i thought i'd connect
you because she might be able to help
you or
is it literally as simple as that simple
as that there's there's no
there's no science behind it it's just
like okay cool you do this
and it's relative or relevant to this
person so
why don't i connect you to one one thing
i would obviously
be a little bit cautious of is if you've
got a hiring manager and you keep
connecting him to
you know potential candidates you're
probably not going to make money
but if you are hiring leaders with other
leaders or other data scientists with
other data scientists
and they you know they've posted
something recently or you perhaps tagged
that person in their post
just just connecting people people
appreciate that
yeah and i think what i love about that
and i've experienced this in my own
career is like basically it's the
mindset of
giving more than you take right and
actually
what actually ends up happening is you
end up getting more in return anyway
when you actually do that in the real
honest way you know what i mean i agreed
and
that's that's the key point if you're
doing it authentically if you
if you're actually doing it because you
want to make the community better
but obviously we're recruiting so there
is a you know there is a
an underlying thing there that we want
to pick up business but if you're doing
it because you're interested in the
space
and that that would that would probably
be another thing like it's very easy to
to find interest in something if if you
actually pick a vertical that you're
interested in
or a space that actually excites you
it's very interesting
it's very easy to pick up skill and
knowledge around it and
natural language if you look back at my
school days which i hated
um i probably would have never thought
that i'd be
working very closely with linguists um
in fact i probably didn't even know what
linguist was but there's something
really
interesting about language that that
actually makes
my ability to be able to talk to people
much more genuine
yeah okay so where do you think most
people go wrong with client development
follow-ups yeah
follow-ups like more so i think
people tend to to follow up with an
agenda like they're always trying to get
something out of it again
coming back to adding that value so
client development isn't again it's not
a short-term thing you will get
short-term wins
sometimes i think i actually hold the
record of darwin for
the fastest ever placement made with
sort of 19 hours from picking up a new
business finding a new candidate and
having them sign a contract
on a perm role with like three
interviews yeah so it ca
i'm i'm testament it can happen really
quick but if you don't do anything with
it thereafter
then you're not going to build a
relationship with that client and so
many times i see people that
do great work with the business they do
maybe one two sometimes three placements
and then you never hear anything more
about that business ever again
because they get side they get you know
i guess distracted or sidetracked
and start doing the same for another
business and the same for another
business and same for another business
and then when they look back on the year
and they go well who are your clients
and they go uh i did some placements but
i haven't got any clients
so i think following up showing a
genuine interest in those businesses
understanding the projects yes we're
recruiters but there's so many other
ways that we can actually add value to
that team
again whether that be introducing them
to people whether that be bringing them
on a podcast
whether that be sharing relevant
knowledge or competitors knowledge with
them
data on the market like there's just so
many things you can do to continue
adding value
beyond just placing people in their team
yeah
love that so so recruiters might be
listening now listen be going okay well
how
how do i make sure i do that with the
right clients
so how how do you sort of judge it
yourself or what do you look for for you
to go you know what
one i need to have a bit of a plan as to
how i take this client from two free
placements a year to six seven eight
but like what what do you look for in
from a client relationship to be like
right i need to make sure
that i put more effort into this to
expand in this account
it's kind of weird because i'm not i'm
not entirely sure that i can give a fair
response to that because i don't
necessarily have a strategy
it's just in me to stay in touch
it's just it's just important that i
i never well i tried not to look back at
business god when was the last time i
contacted them
like i always know that i'm doing
something with them and and try not to
over stretch like you don't need
50 clients you really don't to be
successful
you can have five maybe 10 businesses 10
even a stretch
five businesses that you just see as as
as your
next 12 months of of success and you
just invest all of your time into
getting to know those companies
i think just don't over stretch yourself
and it's and it's kind of easy to then
stay in touch with people and to
constantly loop them into things you're
doing
that that for me is is how i've seen
success in in the relationships i've
built
now that makes sense i guess because you
do stay in touch so much you've got
a real understanding of where the
business is going and yes i guess
if you just have a lot of touch points
and you're like well actually they've
just told me that
they um failed with securing more
funding or they've just got fundings
like right that that will spur that on i
guess right now because you're
you're making sure you've already you've
always always got current context
that i guess will encourage you to be
like ryan instead on top of that or
actually i probably need to start
looking at getting more referrals or
whatever do you know what i mean
yeah i will say as well that in the
american market as i mentioned earlier
that you do have a lot more
relationships with
internal recruiters those those internal
recruiters out here move
quite often so you can pick up a
business build a great relationship
and that's and that's good because
wherever that internal recruitment might
go next
you might end up building a relationship
there but if you don't
create multiple points of contact in
that business as soon as that recruiter
leaves
you've got no chance of working in that
business you've then got to restart that
whole process of trying to build a
relationship with someone who and it
doesn't matter if you made six
placements there or not
so having multiple points of contact in
a business is super
is super important and that creates more
opportunity as well for people to
to reference your work internally yeah
that's a really good point especially
when
if if you've learned free mistakes that
the best way to get in with businesses
is internal recruitment
i'm assuming you've had to that's where
you start because you don't rub them up
the wrong way and that's what you did
wrong
but and then i'm assuming once you've
started to form that relationship
what then do you openly communicate that
look it'd be great if i could
communicate to x or i don't know like
how
how do you then expand that because i
guess like you don't want to rub them up
the wrong way
you just you just lev i mean at the end
of the day they can actually be really
helpful
um and i know that kind of goes maybe
i'm talking about turnip i think that
goes against a lot of
the mindsets of external agencies in in
the european markets
i hate internal recruiters yeah like i
hear all the time so yeah for sure
but that's just that's just not the case
here if you build those relationships
well
you almost won't have to ask for that
that um
opportunity to speak to a high manager
because if you're servicing the world
you're making them look good
you're doing what they ask um
occasionally if you need to push you
push you don't push too often
they'll they'll introduce you to the
business because it's one less thing
that they need to do
one thing to keep in mind here is that a
lot of the internal recruiters
aren't specialists in a vertical either
so i have a conversation
they do everything i spoke to a business
recently and they were looking for
for 12 immediate hires in engineering
and then 30 over the next 12 months
but and i was like okay well that's huge
growth and there was like oh there's
only two of us and i was like
wow that's a lot just for two of you she
said no no that's just engineering i've
got 120 rolls i was like
oh okay so how can you how can you
service
your business as two three people for
120
you can't it's too many and you can't
specialize so
they do really value these specialist
relationships so if you bring
a niche to the table and you can add
value and you understand the business
and you respect the process that they're
giving you because they're all slightly
different you just have to
i guess you just have to become a little
bit more emotionally intelligent with
the uh the people that you're working
with and and
you know i'm not necessarily someone to
be told what to do all the time
but you kind of do have to honor the
process and that process
will create opportunity for you if you
stick to it and and you continue
bringing value
since the time to start us all together
then lewis is like
american market like internal
recruitment
you need to make sure you're on their
side you're building relationships
don't yeah go rubbing everyone out the
wrong way
and then also as you're just saying like
make sure
that you make them aware how much value
you can bring your specialist and that
goes a long way
so i guess what what has been your most
successful way then to wrap this
together of
building these relationships is internal
recruiters is it just again just staying
in touch
delivering value respecting the process
just doing those things then when they
do give you that opportunity they do
give you that branch
you grab it with both hands and
absolutely deliver a high level of
service
yeah there's there's nothing there's
nothing more to that really i'm not
saying that you just have to do it
again you don't have to do everything
they tell you to do in terms of like
following the process you can speak to
the higher managers like as long as
you're as long as you're including them
in stuff
you know if there was a if there was a
reason for you to reach out to
the hiring manager you're supporting as
long as they're involved in the process
they're pretty cool with giving you
freedom they just want to have some
level of oversight and again like we're
here to make them look good as much as
we are us look good so
as long as you're as long as you're
expressing that and letting them know
that that's why you're here
and not to to you know to to damage
their career in any way like
for me that's been the key to success
yeah love that
it took you 18 months or so to get to
the market you needed to and then you
that's when you moved over to america
where did you initially live then
lewis where did you move to so moved to
boston
um the four of us actually three of us
sorry
moved into a a shared house or apartment
which was in hell living together i
hated it
oh yeah yeah i hated it yeah
yeah it was um and don't get wrong i
loved
and still do the guys that were in my
team at the time um they've kind of gone
into different journeys now themselves
but
um we had we had a good time but it was
in a depth of winter when we arrived it
was like uh they called it a bomb
cyclone
no joke got off the plane ice hit me
from this direction
really wind hit me from this direction
it was like what have we done
like where are we so we were like
confined
to the office and then straight back to
this apartment with the same people all
the time and it was
outside of it being exciting being
somewhere new we really couldn't go and
do much
so we just spent a lot of time together
which
it was again it was fun but it just
wasn't for me i didn't move out there
yeah i didn't move out there for that
reason um but that being said
we needed that time to to actually go
and find ourselves an apartment and move
out and stuff so
i moved into my own apartment and um
and actually now i've moved just just
slightly outside of the city
um on the basis that we've actually
decided to go fully remote as a
as a us entity now and that's given us
the ability to be able to
to hire way more people and and much you
know much better talent which
actually reverting back to something we
said earlier when we were talking about
atlanta
we thought that would be really
difficult to hire boston's even harder
and i think a common problem that i've
seen in european agencies that have come
to america
is that it's very difficult to hire
americans because there is
because there's such a great career path
for internal recruiters
you can go into a business have your
lunch paid for
create you know have a great environment
comfortability 401k
healthcare benefits because by the way
they cost a bomb that people don't even
consider when they get here
the cost of staying healthy is um like
unbelievable here
really um yeah um like 6 700 a month you
spend
on on health care benefits if you're if
you're not covered by your business
wow that's before you go to the doctors
and then they smash you with a two grand
deductible
so it's like yeah things you need to
consider but
there's this illustrious career that you
can go and work internally
go straight in on 100k and and like
have none of the stress that you would
in an external agency when it comes to
going out and winning business so it's
it was very difficult to be able to
convince people to come and join a
startup that no one knew
about in an office space that at the
time was dated
so it wasn't that attractive in terms of
a location to work
we actually upgraded it to a wework
office that made a big difference
um and and then to say okay cool well
we're going to pay half you
half the amount of money as a base
salary than you would if you were
working for one of these
really cool companies that everyone
wants to work for it was just hard
and i think this this this now remote
opportunity covert has done us wonders
in that respect it's forced our hand we
were kind of going in that direction
anyway
but it's forced our hand then we've
already made two really really good
hires that uh that one has joined us and
one that's going to be joining us
in mid-november amazing so how is the
american business done performance-wise
there mate so gave us a bit of an
insight into 18 months had the target
like how's the trajectory been since
you've been over there in terms of
billings and stuff like that
so in the first 18 months you know it
was it was
i guess i want to call it a research
trial and error period
yeah and when we got here
to be honest we were still figuring out
the direction
so we still had one of our consultants
doing a lot of work in georgia in san
francisco we had
a few clients in boston we were doing
some stuff in new york
and it was kind of like trial and error
um and
i guess you you almost don't factor in
some of the challenges as well of of
moving people from one country to
another
from a personality perspective like from
a from a they're no longer at home and
they struggle with other things
and the first few years were slow like
i can't sit here and say that we were
super successful over the last
over the last year though in the last
kind of 12 to 16 months we've seen much
more success
and we're now i think we probably closer
to the million dollar mark
from last year and we're probably on
target to achieve that or 1.1
1.2 million realistically i believe our
business
really started about 16 months ago when
we finally had a strategy when we
finally had a team and we finally
created an environment that people
wanted to work in
um we just wasted a few years
and i'm sure like i'm sure if my ceo
could
claw back some of that cash and time he
would and i would i would love to be
able to do that for him but
you know i guess it created the
foundation of where we are now and
i know that that would be a good
investment long term when we look back
and be like okay cool
at least we figured out what not to do
yeah so i'm definitely going to ask you
for those uk agencies uk recruiters
looking to come over to america like
how they should approach it whatever
from your learnings but
but before we finish mate like just you
talking about there the challenges and
what you had to go through
like you do strike me as someone that
has um really cultivated
resilience like what's been your journey
in that in terms of lewis's mindset
um and what helped you mentally get
through that period because you're in a
completely different country
i haven't got your family that i'm
assuming obviously with your guys that
you're sitting 24 hours a day which
would have been
[ __ ] annoying right so like what like
how did you get through that mentally
what
what did you do there so it wasn't it
wasn't something i developed when i got
here
if i'm being honest we we spent a lot of
time together as a team
and in those initial 18 months there was
a level of dedication that we all
you know we we put our personal lives
aside and we committed to each other
that this is what we were going to do
and this is and without each other we
couldn't get
to america yeah collective goal
and what made it very easy is although i
didn't want to live with these guys
um they they were people i wanted to be
around
we created a albeit you know it was it
was only three or four of us it was a
culture that i just wanted to wake up
and be involved in every day
i didn't want to wake up and be involved
in that at home but i wanted to go to
the office and
and and their motivation motivated me
so it was a collective effort and i
think
that's what kept us all sane and that
being said you know we're in a new
environment it was just exciting
yeah from a personal perspective i just
don't like losing
really i just i really don't like losing
um
i guess in my honestly my older age in
my 30s now
um i'm 30 by the way not in my 30s that
makes me sad
i guess i guess i've become a better a
better loser
um i just i hated coming second
i hated it with a passion and
for me to have people look at me on a
personal level and say well you failed
crushed me so i was like i have to win
i i have to come out here and make this
successful and
actually funnily enough did that mean
that it was i was the right person to be
leading the team
actually in time we realized that
there's probably someone better suited
to that and that i can motivate the team
and be part of the team in a different
way which is then when i moved into this
this more um director of business
development
based position where i still have a lot
of involvement in
mentoring and working alongside the guys
and bringing in business and that kind
of stuff
but we brought in a fantastic team
leader who just understands
how to to manage people in a team that
perhaps
is still quite junior um so just
being accepted of the fact that i can't
be great at everything
and and to then focus on you know a few
things the same with the clients
bring in a few clients and focus on them
like hone in a few of your skills and
focus on those skills and have other
people around to support you
yeah that's what got me through it yeah
and then and then that being said
coming to america with an english accent
mate
it makes it very easy to make friends
oh honestly i didn't believe it until i
came here
yeah i didn't believe it and just you
you were we are we talking about guy
mates are we talking about birds
both both honest honestly both you
just just people want to know you um
people want to talk to you we we
boston has a very good fitness scene and
the guys that were in the team at the
time were all into fitness so we went to
this gym and it was just full of people
and we were the only english people
there so everyone wanted to train with
us
um and then look without going into too
much depth i've got a
you know i've got a baby on the way and
a very secure relationship
but it helped
free bets free best bits of advice then
for recruiters that are like
that really like the opportunity or like
the sound of opportunity or taking their
recruitment career
career to america hopefully that can
still happen with all the madness that's
going on but like
what would your free bet best bits of
advice be for for those looking to take
their career to the
to the states i would say
again going back to patients be patient
don't expect to hit the ground running
i don't expect uh to be able to bring
the skill sets you have and then just
work here
you have to you have to adapt um
i think be prepared for change because
everything changes not just the market
that you're doing recruitment in your
entire life changes
it's as much a mental game as it is
anything else
when you get here you don't have the
resources that you had at home you can't
go out
with your mates on a friday for beers
you can once you've got mates
but that period of time when you get
here is difficult
especially if you're not someone who's
really comfortable going up to talking
and talking to random people
so mentally you need to be prepared for
that disconnect you're going to be on
your own
even if your business is with you even
if your colleagues are by your side
there are going to be times where you
sit there going oh my god
i don't know anyone like i can't be
prepared for that yeah
be really really prepared for that that
i would say that's probably where a lot
of people fail
and they just get homesick um
and then finally be prepared for
the success like doing a placement
in europe is cool and you can earn good
money but doing one in america
when it's worth four times more than it
is in europe
you earn a lot of money and and you can
earn it very quickly
and i would say just be prepared for
that so
it can play as much into the mental game
as as when you earn a load of cash don't
just go out and spend it all at once
because you're back in that lonely place
again with no money like be strategic
with how you save and invest your money
um which i've started to do more so now
i guess with my responsibilities that
are pending
um i did i did have fun you know we were
on the tables we were dropping thousands
of dollars we were buying nice suits and
we did all that when we first got here
and you know we saw
the short-term success but just just
have a plan for
how you're going to manage your success
um and
it will just put you in a great mental
state and
that that would be my three tips really
yeah no i love that and i don't think
enough people talk about that lewis so
thank you for sharing
yeah you just hear about people buying
all the nice things and all that right
um it doesn't mean it does it doesn't
mean anything
it's actually at the end of the day like
you can have a rolex but i have 100
bucks in your account and you're not
rich
you look you look rich but you're not
yeah exactly
um looks i've got five
quick five questions for you mate all
right let's go
all right let's go don't have to you
don't have to answer them quickly but
i'm just i'm just going to hit you with
five questions all right so
first one if you could change the
industry
what would you improve
if i could change industry what would i
improve people's
people's perception of recruiters
um there's a very negative connotation
around
our industry and
i can understand why in certain cases
but if there was one thing i could
change it would be
business's perception of recruiters and
that if they didn't slam the door
as soon as we picked up the phone or
sent an email
because of the fact that we called a
recruiter that would
that would change a lot because we we
bring value i truly believe that
yeah what book have you read that has
had the biggest impact on you
i've got to be honest i'm not a book
reader audible
i i've got i like listening to like
the cheesy motivational youtube videos
of like the rock or e.t
um getting me and uh it's pretty sad but
i listen to them in the morning when i'm
in the shower
all right all right let's do that what's
your go-to motivational video in the
morning that gets you
cheated up i like i like eric thomas
where he talks about you know walking
into the sea and
and keep going keep going and until you
can't breathe
um and that's that's when you know
yeah et is the man
if uh if you could write a linkedin post
that could be seen by
every single recruitment consultant
across the world
what would you want it to say
ah what would i want it to say
that's a tough one man
i think you might have stumped me
uh list listen start listening stop
talking
like that what did you spend your first
biggest commission pay check on uh i
bought car
yeah i at the time it was an a-class
mercedes
um it was brand new in the uk at the
time
white leather interior it was all
tricked out with the amg kit on it
um felt like a badass because yeah yeah
yeah it was like it was like a poor
man's mercedes
it had all of the bells and whistles but
it was the cheapest one in the range but
it still felt good
love that mate last one what's the
ultimate goal
for your recruitment career
honestly i think asking me this question
six months ago probably wouldn't be
but to create a very good stable
foundation for my family
um i have a baby on the way my
perspectives changed
and it and i'm sure it will come march
4th if he arrives on time
um don't worry i've got a bet on it
because i'm competitive
but i would say just create instability
for my family whilst also
not not sacrificing the niceties
you know what i'm not doing is just
putting money away for his college
degree
like i'm not i'm not sacrificing going
out for nice meals and having a good
time and and like surprising
my girlfriend with gifts and sending
stuff back home i'm never going to
sacrifice those things
but i want to make sure that i'm able to
do that comfortably with no worries and
i know that recruitment can give me that
platform
so do i do i have a career goal in mind
i'm not entirely sure of how high i can
go i think that
the sky's the limit but but yeah that's
the that's the aim
lewis been a pleasure lovely appreciate
it